sur larry king maintenant l'étoile de la panthère noire de marvel
chadwick boseman ça va être
incroyable pour les
petits enfants euh pas seulement qui sont noirs
mais euh de toutes les races pour voir ce
personnage parce que je pense qu'il
élargit notre conscience et élargit
notre esprit sur
ce qu'est un héros  on dirait que chaque fois que vous faites
quelqu'un qui est réel,
je sens que vous devez prendre une décision
sur la façon dont vous voulez le faire, il y a
différentes façons de le faire, c'est comme
pour 42 brian helgeland était catégorique sur
le fait que je ne devrais pas
imiter la voix de jackie il  a estimé que l'
essence de
trouver l'essence de qui était jackie
robinson plus
aaron jimenez peut larry king faire une
apparition dans le prochain
connu
pour ses représentations acclamées de jackie
robinson dans le film
42 james brown and get on up and
thurgood marshall in marshall
chadwick a également été présenté au
monde en tant que super-héros noir  panthère
dans la guerre civile de capitaine amérique de marvel
maintenant
il ramène le personnage préféré des fans
sur grand écran
dans son premier blockbuster solo de merveille
appelé bien sûr
panthère noire il doit sortir le 16 février
au fait chadwick boseman tu n'as pas
changé ton nom non c'est mon nom
ce n'est pas un nom de scène non, il a été
récemment rapporté que ce sont les 24 premières
heures de prévente, la panthère noire a
vendu des billets plus avancés
que tout autre film merveilleux qu'en pensez-vous
euh c'est quelque chose de nouveau c'est quelque chose que nous
n'avons jamais vu auparavant
euh je pense que beaucoup de gens
ont été enthousiasmés par le film
euh depuis que Marvel a annoncé que
ce serait un film solo
euh j'ai toujours su que même quand j'ai fait
la guerre civile
le personnage a été présenté j'ai toujours
su qu'il y aurait un film solo
mais je pense que la façon dont ils ont construit le
personnage dans euh
la guerre civile la façon dont nous l'avons amené
à
deux publics et euh cette annonce
c'est juste quelque chose que les gens
euh ils sont ravis de s  ee quelque chose qu'ils
n'ont jamais vu avant
qu'est-ce que ça fait de jouer quelque chose comme
ça
je veux dire c'est un gars de super-héros,
euh j'essaie j'essaie de
me concentrer sur l'humanité du
personnage plus
que sur l'aspect super-héros du
personnage
parce que j'ai l'impression que vous savez que nous pouvons tous nous
identifier
à l'humanité, nous pouvons tous nous identifier
aux défauts du personnage, nous pouvons tous nous
identifier à lui,
vivre, respirer, manger et
faire des choses régulières,
je pense que nous avons aussi des
aspirations à faire quelque chose de plus grand
que  nous
-mêmes et nous avons aussi des moments où nous
ne pouvons pas comprendre comment nous avons fait quelque chose,
nous avons nos propres moments de super-héros,
alors j'essaie de l'amener à un endroit où
nous pouvons tous l'atteindre,
vous savez, c'est comme ça que je le joue
est-ce que jackie robinson est venue avant ça
avant les vengeurs oh oui oui jackie
était votre percée
oui 42. je n'avais aucune idée quand j'ai fait
42 que euh
que je serais ici en ce moment euh
jouant un super-héros
comme si c'était la fourrure  la chose la plus importante dans mon
esprit,
wow, c'est quand le film a-
t-il été terminé, ils ont dit que cela faisait longtemps que tout le monde l'
attendait depuis longtemps,
nous avons terminé euh l'année dernière 2017.
euh je suppose que nous avons terminé en
avril et ensuite nous avons eu quelques reprises
euh un  un peu plus tard en novembre donc euh c'est
tout droit sorti des presses
étiez-vous un fan de la bande dessinée quand vous étiez enfant quand vous étiez
enfant non
euh on m'a présenté le personnage
à l'université euh
et je pense que Reginald Hudlin a
fait une série de panthère noire pour
que  était la première série que j'avais
lue
dans son intégralité, mais en tant qu'enfant,
vous savez que je ne savais même pas que le
personnage
grandissait, c'est le premier film de
Marvel entièrement centré sur un super-héros noir,
pensez que cela vous ajoute de la pression
oui absolument  euh
à ce stade je ne ressens pas nécessairement
la pression mais je pense
euh quand ils m'ont initialement approché
pour le faire euh
je savais que c'était quelque chose que nous
devions avoir la bonne
équipe pour le faire nous devions avoir le bon
réalisateur  et euh
euh le bon producteur là-dessus,
j'avais l'impression qu'ils devaient avoir la bonne
approche et s'y engager d'une
manière où
ils avaient l'impression que toute leur carrière était
en jeu, vous savez
parce que je pense que c'est si important
si
vous tournez  on a tourné à atlanta à
atlanta en géorgie pas en afrique pas en
afrique
non la périphérie d'atlanta en géorgie
ou
notre afrique et notre film tu tournes en
été
on a tourné euh en hiver
et au printemps bien ouais pour l'été
[Rires
] c'est  ça doit être fascinant pour vous, je
veux dire que vous avez eu des
rôles incroyables et que vous avez eu une grande
visibilité, mais
cela va bien passer par le toit
à ce stade, euh juste à partir des préventes,
c'est une énorme réalisation
euh tu sais je  Je suis plus intéressé de
voir
comment les gens réagissent quand ils le
voient réellement et
je suis très enthousiaste à ce sujet,
mais ça va être incroyable, ça
va être incroyable pour les
petits enfants euh pas seulement qui sont noirs
mais euh de toutes les races à  voir ce
personnage  euh parce que je pense que cela
élargit notre conscience, cela élargit
notre esprit sur
ce à quoi ressemble un héros était-ce difficile pour
vous de préparer
oui ceci ceci euh j'ai toujours dit que
james brown était probablement
le personnage le plus difficile
à jouer parce que vous savez qu'il y a  tant
d'aspects différents de
vous savez, il y a la danse, il y a le
chant, il y a
le personnage lui-même, les différentes
itérations de qui
il est, je pense que cela rivalise définitivement avec
lui parce que c'est physiquement exigeant,
je pense que l'aspect culturel de l'
accent
qui il est en tant que  un leader mondial euh
toutes ces choses sont
très compliquées donc
ça rivalise avec james brown wow
jackie doit avoir été amusant à faire il était
oh mec
42. saviez-vous que vous faisiez un grand
film
c'est une question que je ne fais pas  pense que
tout le monde sait ouais
parce que vous pouvez vous pouvez avoir euh
vous pouvez avoir une expérience formidable en faisant un
film et cela ne
se passe pas exactement comme vous le
pensiez ou les gens
ne le font peut-être pas '  Je ne réponds pas comme vous
pensez qu'ils le feraient et vous pourriez avoir une
expérience difficile en faisant un film
et tout d'un coup tout le monde l'aime
donc je ne pense pas que vous puissiez jamais dire que
je pense euh avec 42
j'ai aimé travailler avec euh avec brian
hill
glenn j'apprécie à quel point c'était difficile parce
que tu as joué au ballon tu veux
dire dis-tu avant que nous,
joueur de baseball, je joue je joue littéralement
probablement jusqu'à
12 ans et moins mais ce n'était pas quelque chose que
j'avais joué depuis des années
alors nous devions y aller  à travers un très très
intense euh
vous savez l'entraînement de printemps vous ressemblez à un
joueur de balle
ouais d'accord eh bien nous le faisions nous le
faisions
système de conduite à distance activé
attendez de quel côté de la route est ce
bâton de bus frappez juste d'
accord calmez-
vous allons-y
hé  regarde ton costume tu as pris des
balles en le chargeant avec de l'énergie cinétique
placée autour du
camion nous sommes de retour avec chadwick boseman il
joue dans la panthère noire ça arrive le
16 février et tout le monde attend on
me dit que votre intérêt initial pour
le film était de réaliser
euh écrire indirect oui oui euh comment avez-vous
viré du côté de l'acteur
euh je pense que je pense que mon intérêt a
toujours été
pour la plupart quel que soit l'
effort artistique le plus épanouissant
et je pense que les rôles d'acteur ont
commencé à me venir à l'esprit  était-
ce que
c'était aussi épanouissant que des choses que je
pourrais écrire que je pourrais
finir par diriger et donc ces deux
aspects de
mon art se produiront et se produiront
même au moment où nous parlons, vous savez très bien
quelques choses comment avez-vous obtenu le
partie de robinson
je suis entré et j'ai lu pour cela je suis entré et j'ai
lu
pour vicky thomas et pour brian helgeland
[Musique]
tu sais que je ne m'y attendais pas à ce
moment-là
parce que je pense que je voulais retourner à
new york
tu savais  juste la vie à new york et
l'inspiration de new york dans mon cerveau
et la ne me traitait peut-être pas
aussi bien que je le pensais et donc
je sais juste que je suis entré en pensant que je
n'allais pas obtenir  et puis ils m'ont appelé
et m'ont dit h  ey
là, ils veulent que vous y jouiez, ils veulent que
vous reveniez une fois de plus et que vous fassiez
un essai de baseball,
mais vous savez que cela pourrait être une grande
chose, donc
cela a fini par se produire quand je
m'attendais le moins à ce que cela mène à james brown
dans  d'une certaine manière, c'est arrivé d'une manière étrange
parce que
je recevais des scripts et euh
certains d'entre eux étaient des auteurs certains d'entre eux
étaient des auditions
euh celui-ci en particulier ii
quand j'ai vu james l'histoire de james
brown j'étais comme
si personne ne devrait jamais faire ça
personne ne pouvait essayer  que vous savez et donc euh
je l'avais refusé sans même le
lire
et ils n'arrêtaient pas de me
dire euh nous pensons que vous devriez
vraiment entrer et
rencontrer tate taylor le réalisateur et
lire pour cela et donc j'ai en fait
accepté de  entrer je pense qu'après trois
fois ils m'ont demandé et j'ai dit que je
vais lire pour ça je vais faire un
travail terrible
et ça ne marchera pas je vais le faire
exploser et
ils m'ont montré qu'ils avaient fini  me montrant
l'audition
et alors que je regardais le  audition j'ai dit
attendez une minute
peut-être que je peux le faire alors j'ai vu que je l'ai vu
après que vous savez que vous l'avez refusé vous savez
plusieurs fois
avez-vous chanté euh ou avez-vous la bouche j'ai fait les
deux
j'ai fait les deux la synchronisation labiale est très difficile et
donc c'était un  décision que nous devions prendre euh
personne n'avait une voix comme ça
ouais et et personne ne veut entendre tu
veux entendre james brown réel
cette voix réelle je pense que c'est dans
un biopic musical
comme ça la décision devrait je pense
devrait être
de  entendre la personne que nous qui nous aimons
cet aspect devrait être cette personne
mais il y avait un mélange je devais en
chanter quelques-uns je devais en chanter quelques-uns
parfois et et parfois c'est ma
voix et sa voix
mais c'est surtout sa voix Dieu merci
Parlez-moi de l'expatrié, qu'est-ce qu'on
ne peut pas vraiment en parler
comme pour l'instant ouais c'était tous les
secrets
[Rires]
eh bien c'est Barry Jenkins qui le dirige
euh
il a fait du bon clair de lune, il a
fait du clair de lune
et euh tu sais que c'est un  c'est un
thriller c'est un euh avion h  ijacking qui
est assis autour de
centres autour et joue au détournement mais
nous ne voulons pas dévoiler l'intrigue pour l'
instant parce que
euh je vais te demander c'est toi le
pirate de l'air
ne peut pas répondre à papa d'
accord je ne peux pas répondre que
tu me veux  vouloir que je raconte l'
histoire hé peut-être que je sauve les gens
pendant le pirate de l'air quand est-ce que les expatriés
commencent à tourner ça devrait être plus tard cette
année euh
je pense que ce sera à l'automne
mais c'est
nous devons travailler sur nos horaires
parce que nous sommes tous les deux super occupés en ce moment
donc vous n'avez pas encore fait de tournage non
non pas du tout pas du tout après la pause
la star de la panthère noire
chadwick boseman joue un jeu spécial de
si vous saviez seulement que c'est le prochain
sur cette édition de larry  roi maintenant
nous sommes de retour avec l'énorme talent
chadwick
boseman il joue dans la panthère noire le
16 février lorsque vous jouez des
personnages que les gens connaissent les gens connaissaient
jackie robinson certainement d'un certain
âge vous le connaissiez en tant que joueur
tout le monde connaissait james brown est-ce
ha  rder
oui, je pense que vous savez
faire un personnage historique
que les gens savent, c'est à
chaque fois que vous faites quelqu'un qui est réel, j'ai l'
impression que
vous devez prendre une décision sur la façon dont
vous voulez le faire, il y a différentes
façons de le faire, c'est comme
pour 42 brian helgeland  était catégorique sur
le fait que je ne devrais pas utiliser
je ne devrais pas imiter la voix de jackie
il a estimé que l'essence de trouver l'
essence de qui était jackie robinson
il avait une voix très spéciale qu'il avait s'il
avait une voix spéciale il n'avait pas d'
argot
non  il n'a pas non, il est très hétéro et
euh,
mais il a estimé que vous savez que
vous pouvez parler dans la période, mais
il s'agit du fonctionnement interne de qui
cet homme n'est pas l'imitation de qui est l'
homme,
donc c'était un  prise particulière de cette
directive qui, je pense, a
fonctionné et je pensais qu'il était comme si cela
enlèverait à
ce que nous faisons en termes de recherche de l'
esprit de ce personnage
si vous entrez dans une imitation de lui euh
c'est très différent pour james brown
vous  sais que je  Dans ce cas, nous avons pensé
qu'il était nécessaire de trouver que vous connaissiez
sa voix pour trouver son mouvement pour trouver que
vous connaissiez le plein
ce n'est pas une imitation mais c'est une
représentation de ce que les
gens connaissent comme les caractéristiques extérieures
aussi longtemps que le  intérieur donc c'est
plus une expérience extérieure et de
travail donc thurgood marshall n'était pas
largement connu je veux dire que
nous les connaissions nous n'avions pas de
groupe de télévision vous n'avez pas vu d'
interviews avec euh
marshall n'importe où pour que cette
expérience soit
vous  sais différent des deux
parce que
vous savez que le truc avec le marshall
était
quand j'ai lu le script ce que j'ai
aimé c'est que je n'avais pas
nécessairement besoin de savoir qui était thurgood marshall
pour profiter de ce film euh moi
et évidemment le  d'autres personnes travaillant
dessus, nous avons dû faire nos recherches et
être
corrects et exacts à propos de euh, vous en
savez autant que possible sur qui il était, mais
je savais aussi que je ne lui ressemblais pas, ce qui
n'était pas du tout
pas du tout donc  plus grand il  avier ouais
et bien il y a une période où
il était en fait maigre aussi bien que
vous sachiez que ça devait être jeune ouais
ses jeunes années les années où
nous le jouons
il était beaucoup plus mince mais en termes de
teint je
Je savais que je ne lui ressemblais en rien et que
j'avais des réserves quant à jouer le rôle à
cause de cela
et c'est en fait son fils qui m'a écrit une
lettre
disant qu'il voulait que je joue euh
jouer son père parce qu'il sentait que je
pouvais  capturer à nouveau l'essence
euh c'est ce que vous recherchez tout le temps la
bonne essence est la chose la plus importante
ça ne devrait jamais être
euh une imitation une imitation parce que si
vous imitez la personne parfois
vous vous moquez d'elle
et donc vous voulez  ayez toujours la
partie interne
nous sautons dans un jeu maintenant si vous saviez seulement que
je vous pose juste quelques questions d'accord
je suis nerveux je suis nerveux vous savez que c'était
ouais quelle a été votre rencontre de fan la plus drôle
euh une femme à l'aéroport
euh qui  avait vu james  Brown se lève
et euh
voulait me défier dans un labo de danse
c'était aussi le plus étrange euh non
non j'en ai eu des vraiment très
étranges bien que euh
j'étrange c'était comme si tu connaissais des gens qui se
présentaient à des endroits ils
il n'y a pas  la façon dont ils peuvent connaître mes
activités mais qui apparaissent continuellement
comme des actions sont essentiellement celles qui
sont les rencontres les plus étranges
qui était votre enfance
célébrité écraser
um enfance avez-vous eu une enfance
euh je ne sais pas qui ce serait en
fait
quelle est la meilleure pièce  de conseils que tu as jamais
eu
euh apprends quand dire non
apprends quand dire non quel est le pire
conseil que tu aies eu
euh yolo tu ne vis qu'une fois le
meilleur compliment que tu aies jamais reçu le meilleur
compliment que j'ai jamais reçu
j'écoute habituellement les critiques
tu prendras la direction oui quel est
le plus grand avantage d'être une célébrité
des trucs gratuits
[Rires]
quelqu'un d'autre d'antan tu
voudrais représenter
personne personne d'accord oui
je devrais je devrais être  fini avec ça ouais je
devrais être d'accord avec ça
tu sais que ça n'a jamais été fait sur le film
cyrus addicts
le premier gars tué sur la route ouais
noël
ouais jamais été un film sur eux ouais
euh plaisir coupable
baklava tu sais que
le baklava de la boîte à notes en est un  d'entre eux,
qu'est-ce qu'un luxe, vous ne pouvez pas vivre sans
un luxe, je ne peux pas vivre sans
Jésus, j'ai l'impression que je me sens comme
notre euh, vous savez, notre obsession Internet
est une sorte de luxe comme personne ne peut vivre
sans que personne ne peut vivre sans
personne ouais ouais alors y a-t-il un
film à venir que vous êtes ravi de voir
je suis ravi de voir pacific rim en
fait oh pacific ground ouais
je suis ravi de voir john boyega un
peu ouais
ouais c'est mon collègue mon collègue acteur je
veux  regarde ce qu'il va faire
excité pour lui eh bien c'est bizarre
je n'ai jamais vu la
plus longue période de temps où tu as été éveillé
[Rires]
trois jours probablement trois jours vraiment
ouais ouais probablement trois jours
super pouvoir que tu aimerais avoir  la vraie
vie
euh jew  ish je pourrais geler le temps
geler le temps geler le temps arrêter arrêter le temps
puis me déplacer et faire des trucs et
puis revenir
ouais wow tu es bloqué sur une île déserte
quelles sont les trois choses que tu apportes avec toi
tu dois apporter tu as un tu as  pour
avoir un briquet
euh tu dois avoir des coupes
euh c'est comme un couteau ou une
sorte
euh j'espère avoir une sorte de radio
pour que je puisse avoir
ouais y a-t-il quelque chose que tu as longtemps
cru être vrai et
euh découvert était '  t euh
je ne sais pas ça d'accord et
chadwick boseman dans dix ans
euh j'espère que je suis juste heureux
tu sais ce que je dis j'espère que
tu sais
tout fait euh avec ma famille
que ça euh qui les rend heureux et
euh
tu sais j'espère que leur euh
la vie ce n'est pas à propos de carrières c'est
à propos des expériences de vie que tu as
tu as fait qu'ils ont une famille
je n'ai pas comme femme et enfants
mais j'ai mon
j'ai  une grande famille um cousins et
mes frères et ils sont tous proches tous
proches y  eah
nous avons des questions sur les réseaux sociaux pour
vous eskoblades sur twitter j'adore leurs
noms ils gèrent
chadwick vous êtes une source d'inspiration pour beaucoup
d'enfants et de personnes de couleur
partout dans le monde qui regardent la
panthère noire avec enthousiasme quel message
donneriez-vous à ceux qui sont stimulés  par
la représentation visible dans le nouveau
film
euh iii dirais que vous savez
profiter de ce moment euh vous savez
tout absorber euh et faire de votre mieux
pour le reproduire à votre manière non
seulement dans le film mais aussi d'autres manières
dans notre société quoi  d'autres façons pouvons-nous
innover
et changer les perceptions des gens sur
ce qu'est la réalité c'est de quoi
parle ce moment
vous savez la floride sur le blog de larry king now
vous semblez avoir le goût de
jouer des rôles de leadership
vous considérez-vous comme un vrai
leader
euh  euh eh bien ma réponse est que
je ne semble pas nécessairement voir que
c'est vrai ce ne sont que de grands rôles
euh tu sais si
tu es doué pour ça s'il y a d'autres
rôles que euh exactement je suis un
je suis  un acteur et euh s'il y a d'autres
rôles qui ne sont pas nécessairement des
leaders mais qui sont intéressants
je suis tout aussi intéressé par ceux-là aussi donc
ceux-ci viendront aussi
lana fallon sur le blog de larry king maintenant
quels sont certains de vos souvenirs préférés
de travailler sur le film
42 souvenirs préférés euh
je pense que le premier jour euh
était très intéressant parce que euh quelle était
la première chose que
nous avons tournée euh en fait c'était en fait
la deuxième la première scène de baseball euh que
nous avons tournée était une scène de la ligue noire
euh et ainsi de suite  c'était juste que c'était intéressant
de commencer à partir de cet endroit pour commencer à
partir de
vous savez ce moment de sa vie euh
c'est chronologique euh
et nous étions je pense euh le
coordinateur des cascades et je me disputais sur la
façon dont jackie glisse
alors toi euh et moi  l'avais étudié
comme vous le savez, nous avions un écran partagé moi
glissant et pratiquant et euh
et euh et lui glissant donc
je le savais je savais que j'avais raison à ce sujet donc
c'est ça qui me vient à l'esprit à
cause de cet argument  t
qui a gagné j'ai gagné avez-vous aimé travailler avec
mon ami harrison ford en
fait je lui ai parlé hier euh
ouais j'ai adoré euh
j'aime toujours lui parler je pourrais avoir des nouvelles
de lui à tout moment
un gars spécial un peu sur le larry king
maintenant  blog combien de temps vous a-t-il fallu pour
tourner la panthère noire
et dans quelles villes avez-vous tourné uniquement à
atlanta le seul plan à atlanta
euh combien de temps le film prendra-t-il, nous avons
tourné je veux dire de janvier à avril
mais la période de préparation était beaucoup
plus longue  que ça,
donc on a l'impression que c'était une année entière
[Rires]
peu a également demandé s'il avait fallu longtemps pour
mettre le costume de panthère noire
qu'ils obtenaient si nous devenions plus rapides
au début, il fallait
trois personnes pour entrer
maintenant, c'est juste moi et une autre
personne trois trois
personnes supplémentaires de la taille de moi pour entrer
dans euh
ça devient plus léger aussi donc
tu t'y habitues ça ne
me semble plus lourd non
aaron jimenez peut larry king faire un
camée dans le prochain
film de merveille
qui est tha  ce n'est pas une question pour moi
c'est une question pour euh
tu pourrais en parler superstar juive
un superviseur juif vieillissant d'accord d'accord
quelqu'un dans les années 80 d'
accord il pourrait sauter des bâtiments je
tire toujours
donc tu as aussi
des super pouvoirs j'aurais des super pouvoirs d'accord d'
accord nous  pourrais-je appeler
kevin flag et voir si nous pouvons y
arriver
et zono nous pank sur twitter en plus des
expatriés travaillez-vous sur d'autres
nouveaux
projets oui mais je peux dire que vous ne pouvez
rien me dire à ce sujet  oui nous devons
retenir tout ce que
nous avons beaucoup appris sur
le passé de chadwick boseman et rien
sur son avenir non merci mec
merci beaucoup mec
edward bozeman est mon invité assurez-vous de voir
black panther c'est le 16 février et
comme toujours vous pouvez trouver  moi sur twitter aux
choses du roi
et nous vous verrons la prochaine fois que
vous